Gaiman jong-il Madara I have two weeks  to search all of the former Soviet Union  for the superhumans that can stop a  super villain exactly right  these people are our only hope  what's the name of the mission Guardians  we're all the same lair cos arses you  want to know who did this to you  come with us rapid military attacks on  Moscow continue army turned out to be  useless against the opposition forces  all attempts to stop it ended up with a  complete shutdown of any machinery  I've been waiting for this for half a  century there's no coming back for all  of us our experimental laboratory  designed special gear to increase your  performance where's mine game is on  God's Adelle my darling